[MUSIC]
How are you?
Good, nice to meet you.
finally.
what I love seeing people that are kind
of, you know, seeing things on
LinkedIn. It just gives us a few people that
all they seem really good and then they're set up and done the right
thing and I'm like yes come on!
So how long have you been doing?
and you're thankful. Yeah yeah I am.
It's been about a month at the...
this point. Yeah, I uh,
I was working and had been working in
just janitorial facilities management as proposal.
manager for the last about five and a half.
years and then after the third
where the culture was really...
terrible and and I just was
budging up against the...
strictures of having a boss who just fundamentally...
I didn't understand what I was doing.
I'm sure you can relate to that.
>> Yes. >> I'm sorry.
I just wanted to do it on my own.
And then also--
I'm sure you would agree with this, Michelle. The writing's on the wall.
for us in terms of AI.
So that's--
That's a big thing too.
100%
like two years ago I was just thinking.
you know this job as it stands today.
is pretty much toast. Do you know what I mean?
And it feels like this half a world that...
but isn't even seeing.
in that or understand in it or making any.
moves to pivot in any way.
or and it's just a madness.
There's some companies that understand it.
and you know but...
Still, it feels like everyone's lagging behind.
Yeah, I agree.
for now but you know I'm trying to
become an AI engineer before my job.
becomes complete toast.
AI engineer or move into
more sales and enablement type stuff.
Got it. Yeah.
Yeah.
notice you do a bit off as well.
Is that right or?
Yeah, I think.
that you and I are taking a--
similar trajectory where we are seeing how.
So, having a full time employee.
employment situation with an organization to do.
proposal management is is going
to go away because a huge amount of our
work for better for worse can be automated.
Yeah, completely.
100% and I feel I feel
for people not thinking ahead. Do you know what I mean?
Yeah. So what is it?
been like for you trying to drum up business.
Like what-- what--
What does that look like for you?
Well, I've just been in...
incredibly lucky because
I think I've worked hard on...
over the years because I've always disappeared.
likes to the majority of full-time jobs.
So I've always been kind to
of writing stuff on LinkedIn and connecting with people.
And then when I decided to leave...
my job at the end of November.
the last year because I was just I just got
spoken to like an absolute idiot by someone.
who was 15 years my junior who had
Zero experience of better magic thought. No.
And I will...
really crapping myself I was like what have I done?
And then I've just posted that I was...
available for freelance work. And then it's
someone like a woman that I've kind of never...
for my in person but I've always interacted with and she knows
loads of people that I know just said oh!
We've got like a huge government bid on
on, will you do it? And I was like, I've actually done that framework.
before yes so I started on the Monday.
And they are the most disorganized.
organized. (laughs)
Shower of, you know...
It works really well for me that they...
do not qualify properly. They...
management doesn't speak to each other.
Keep saying, "Can we have you next month again?"
So now they're going to put me on a rectangle.
So that's just--
heal lake and then...
I did a bit of a Trojan horse into...
you. We're a bit of a bad-
candid technique I think but I saw
a niche recruitment firm.
Manchester looking for someone to do their bibs.
And so I'm met with them.
and I said, "Oh, well, with me, you wouldn't..."
you wouldn't get me full time for that salary but what I can do.
could do is I could do this and this and this.
And then you could, you know, just
pay me the salary you were going to pay someone full time.
but you're getting someone really senior who
we'll do all the bits and more and thank you.
your strategy and look at all your content and do all of the things.
stuff so yeah they've put me on a machine as well.
I'm just like, oh my god, I'm landed now.
But if
either of those, but to say, oh, we don't need you anymore.
*laughing*
And I've got a few of the little bits and bobs, you know.
people that bring me up and say, 'oh can you do this job?'
this client in Iraq and I'm like what?
Yeah, okay, and I'll do a couple of things.
and that but you know because I've been building
my own agents over the last two years.
guys. Well, I've got the bid bid pretty soon.
up so you know I can work on loads of
simultaneously and still be better.
in my full day rate across three.
three clients like so.
I'm being lucky at the moment but it is pure luck.
and I'm sure that it won't last long.
I'm just like this.
bubbles got to pop anytime soon.
I do have a kind of a question.
of underlying strategy which is
if what does happen. I'm then going to say if I...
can get like a grant from business whales.
And I'll--
thought that I could then start hitting up all the kind of
small.
medium-sized businesses in my life.
Clarya and help them look at their progress.
processes and automation because every
I mean, I live in just more sheep than...
people where I live. So no one understands.
A.I. here. It's just not a thing.
you know, so that's my other car.
of revenue streams.
What about you?
Yeah, I mean what...
what you're describing. I wouldn't.
I, I, your modesty.
is making you I think say that you're lucky.
but what you've described, like there is an underlying strategy.
to it and like you are publicizing and marketing your
Well online. I mean, that's why you and I are speaking
to each other right now. And so, and so.
I think that what's resonating...
about the presence that you've been putting out on LinkedIn is that
that you are somebody who very clearly understands.
AI and I don't need to see any.
products from you to get that, but you are not.
using AI to write and do your
marketing for you. Yeah, definitely.
And that
comes through and so I I
feel like that, that yen that you're in.
you have and it probably comes from you with the artistic
background that you have as a poet and as a singer as a
well, you're able to take
creativity and then channel it into something that
is lucrative for you.
Yeah, I think.
Yeah, I find that to
be inspiring because that is similar to
Like I'm not, I'm not as far along as you are.
And so I want to--
take a similar tack and actually just before you.
when I was speaking, I was looking at local...
uh, janitorial custodial.
firms that are in my area and then trying to.
and shout to them and say like, hey, like, like, I
I imagine that those firms, just like the ones that...
that are around you and Wales are like the owner
are doing the business development, right? Would you say that that's probably
the case for you? Yeah, definitely. Right.
And like they're also doing any number of other
things at the same time. So yeah.
So approaching them and saying, hey, I can--
help you get this organized that can help you win better contracts.
and then take all of the...
The burden of you having to learn how to do it.
that you fundamentally don't know how to do.
- And you don't.
want to learn how to do it and you don't like it.
Yeah, yeah, it's the worst part of
their job a lot of time.
Oh well I hope.
if you've only been going a month and I'm sure...
that you'll, you know, something will...
Yeah.
And
So the sales and a woman stuff then. I don't
no if I actually understand
like do you have to have experience of actually selling?
to do that work.
I wouldn't say so because...
is what I have.
What I've been doing throughout my career is working
directly with salespeople and what I
I've seen with salespeople is that they have
have the soft skills they have the relationships and the human
capital yeah, but I mean to a
person, they are hopeless when it comes to life.
comes to not just technology, but when it comes to order.
and all the other things that you were articulating about.
what you bring to the table. And...
But what's happened when I've been f-
time employed is I
and part of the companies like shared services.
Which means that I am spread thin.
a mud, an enormous amount of bits.
I shipped $400 million in bid.
last year by myself.
the company that I was working for. It was $379.
different proposals. I did that one year.
And I'm not bringing it up because I'm proud
I'm bringing it up because like that's the insanity of
of like how strength in.
people are. And so like for you, you were talking...
about some 80s.
it who doesn't understand what you do.
and it's trying to push you around.
Tell me a little bit about it.
a little bit more about that.
Like what's that dynamic like?
'Cause I think I can relate.
to it. What about being in that
kind of position where your boss...
knows less but thinks they know more.
Yeah.
I don't know really, I just, I don't know.
reached 50 and I just thought I'm not
gonna be spoken to like that. Yeah, yep.
I've been... yeah.
So I think...
know I have to thank him for it in hindsight because
I wouldn't have done this.
I need a...
to put, I'm needed to push because I've been thinking about doing this.
for the last two years, you know?
And I really need...
needed that kind of...
such a huge learning moment for me.
But it's not...
first time I've been in that situation.
And what is it that I'm scared of?
What is it that I'm not quite...
I haven't had the confidence to do it before because that's the only
only differentiating elements.
is the confidence because I have the knowledge.
I've been doing the job for years.
So, you know, it was...
just the confidence and then once I've got that one...
And I was just like right.
- Stop.
(laughing)
And so for you that you were saying that that had come
about because you had basically just put it out there
to the world.
be like, "Hey, I'm ready, willing, and able."
Is that how that went?
Yeah, yeah.
I said that I'm gonna go freelance.
and this is what my specialism is.
It's like the UK public sector.
Right.
global business in recruitment of John facilities management.
of them tech, of them health care.
and just kind of put out
Yeah, what I think I'm good at.
And yeah, I think that's it.
But I think because I have been posting very much.
regularly people will interact with my
content. So that's yes.
that has been beneficial.
For sure. For sure.
So, I am definitely not going to try.
try to ask you about your protected IP.
But I do want to...
curious like what kind of functionality.
you're building into your agents.
when you say that you have agents that are doing things for you.
Yeah, and I'll tell you what I've been building.
as well. I'm just curious what you've been building. Oh cool. Well...
Well, it's more things like...
you know, extracting the question.
doing a first draft from
To be honest, everything is...
changed when Claude co-work.
came into being. So the stuff that I've...
built a lot of.
became kind of redundant overnight.
and I've started kind of rebuilding.
it with cloth. So it's just thing
like I've got a really cool.
good value proposition thing that I've set
up. Nice. So, you know, or risk
search the client and it'll look for kind
of synergies with whatever solution.
or who are from work with.
Right.
Well, it just stells it, you know.
I used to really...
pride myself on that kind of work.
I've written an executive summary, it's taken me a whole day.
really amazing. And it's really amazing.
No, I can now do that in five minutes.
Right.
which it did make me go through
bit of a dark night of the soul you know it's just what what is
my worth, what is my family? And I think
loads of people have into question that. Yeah.
like you know seeing how everyone's linked in headlines.
a change in. I feel like it's really
real proof that everyone is reflecting on
what is my value right now.
which I find really fascinating but um
Yeah, I feel like sometimes I don't have much value.
and what the people are working for.
realize that they can do it themselves.
But they won't because most people are
lazy and they're not selling a lot of life.
right or it might
take such a heavy investment of capital.
to procure a solution that is the
like that self-sustaining or to work with somebody.
that is that self-sustaining that
that they would, they just can't afford to do it.
And so what you're doing is you're bridging the gap between
Hey, I'm not selling you a sandwich.
product. I'm not selling you a loopy over a cubit.
or responsive or whatever the hell they are doing now.
I am selling you my service, but you are
powered by the engine that you yourself are.
creating like I think what we're able to
to do if you're able to engage
with stuff like Cloud Code and Chat GPT codecs as you are able
to strip out the middle person of a developer.
don't need to have that layer anymore.
You are basically just translating directly out of your head
in your experience and that is your differentiator is.
You are channeling that into
this process. It's kind of like your mana
fasting it into software.
- I love that.
Yeah.
Why is it American is a so much better explain than American?
things. That sounds good.
British people are all queer.
Don't want to make a fuss.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so it that is been such an
exciting thing and over the last four weeks in addition to me.
doing lots of outreach and other business development.
like that's what I've been doing is I've just been cooking on
on my Windows VS code.
just like telling it what I want it to build.
And so I'll show you.
quick what I've been building.
It's a version of
what you were talking about, but it's
It's focused currently a lot on captioning.
as opposed to proposal.
development. And so yeah, so I've just made this one.
that is eternal facing only it is not
to be usable or manageable.
to anybody outside of me or outside of me.
profession. I'm just let me know when you can see it.
Okay. Yeah. So, uh,
This is just some dummy data here.
but what I've, what I'm trying to do
right now. And I'd be curious if this would be interesting.
is I am reaching out to
these organizations that probably don't
full-time ED support. So service master.
For example, is...
Not doing anything when I click.
Okay, oh, that's great.
Here it is.
Yeah, so I entered this in it's almost like a
CRM where I enter them in
I have them put into the specific state.
Be sure to have this information for the hearing.
is helping me to create that matter.
between contracts that are coming out today.
and sort of profile. I feel like you were so--
That's kind of like what you have.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's so nice.
What it's great is it has to be...
to tell about this contractor here is a lot of people here.
I can put it in the picture.
[inaudible]
I'm not a cat for a cat.
I think I should have come up and to check.
[inaudible]
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
This is a hot mess.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Hi, I'm Jalsen.
But I suppose I am...
There's a guy called Ian Mc--
and he set up something called...
open opportunities to try.
all UK public sector.
And then you put in
you know, what search terms you want.
and it will bring up any that are relevant.
So I sent him this other thing on the screen.
after spending really changing with people.
that, you know, if you let me use your
software I will recommend it to my
comments. I'm not sure. So.
you know, not only can I see what's
coming up for my clients, I can also start to line up.
you know a pipeline for the next 12 months.
of who I can contact and who is
going for that stuff, but just in terms of intelligence.
It's really, really good.
I think another thing I'll do.
I started to do a realised I got asked by a different person.
Fence company to...
go through all this SC clearance.
and they needed me to see.
to certify that the tools I was using were
like cyber essentials plus and all of this and all of this.
I was like, shhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh.
So then I went to...
a platform called Bidscript because I've been
given them lots of free intelligence over the last two years.
to help them get their product together.
Now I'm using that as well and that's more
or like they've built this multi-agentity.
kind of thing just to strip questions and so.
So I've been using all these.
tools but I think the more you use them the quicker.
you get and I think well no one you know I
I am quite unique in that I've got the access to all this stuff.
and it sounds like your bill
in your own, which is amazing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's time to do it.
That's a lot of other items actually.
Yes.
(mumbles)
and testing.
I think it's a great idea.
It is depressed.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yes.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Absolutely.
[inaudible]
I created this thing that will be...
Yeah, so you know any of the people
that you've worked for in the past is that an option could you say?
that you could...
do a kind of ask to be put on a return.
and do a couple of days a week or anything like that.
that yes I'm happy.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Go get a special update on what you're talking about too.
and I just heard I didn't expect more from you.
Yeah.
So, for you.
I'm not
I'm not. I was planning to.
but I'm not just because of the...
because of a look really.
I have to, no.
So,
But am I in the future?
If I was to lose one of them, then I'd be like...
really in need of doing some kind of
cold outreach. I'm sure that you that's
something as well that you could build for yourself.
quite quickly isn't it?
It seems so much stuff that I actually want to build.
I just haven't had any time.
*unintelligible*
Yes, thank God.
It'll happen, it'll happen.
but build it and they will come now.
thing. But um,
What was it going to say?
What about something?
you based in the US?
I just saw a lot of people. - Okay.
Oh wow, nice.
Yeah, it's... it's...
[SOUND]
Thank you for watching.
[inaudible]
Go get your own hands.
Not at all, not at all.
All my family were like, "Don't do it!"
(laughing)
And so now there is
But I think it was the moment.
stone of turning that significant age and how
having, you know, being spoken to like a
absolutely. You know, I just...
And it was very...
what to call it a knee jerk reaction on my part.
But then I thought, "Shit, I've done it now. I can't go back."
And then I was just like, and then I was just on it.
So warm. Yeah.
But you've got a good idea like have reached.
out to those companies and you know what's coming up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
keep it organized, but it also does.
[inaudible]
Because I want to support people for doing this for me.
Thank you, Rach.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Do you know what?
I think it could be really helpful and it's been so...
something I've been wanting to do so much of.
is. Um.
competitor intelligence.
doing a what analysis of...
You know, the main, the top four.
competitors I think that would be
amazing.
That's a great thing about the opportunity that you're pursuing.
Pretty much.
I'm just thinking, you know, if you could, if you
could design something.
I've made a star on it.
a couple of years back and then I just never fit.
but you know just to be able to put in different ways.
company names and you know what.
what would the play be here, where would the strengths be here, but...
I suppose that's all based on publicly available.
available information whereas.
That's why we've got sales people who can tell us this
stuff that doesn't get released publicly.
Bye!
I'm happy to have you with us.
[inaudible]
I'll see you in my way. (laughs)
(laughing)
Like, it asks the best perspective.
[inaudible]
information. [inaudible]
That's not what I'm supposed to be.
You're a great human being from the future.
[inaudible]
[INAUDIBLE]
*unintelligible*
[inaudible]
Yeah, yeah 100%.
And I think I worked for...
I'm stuck for about a year and a half.
and they were incredible. I've never, never worked.
I worked anywhere as good since.
But their salespeople were in...
incredible. They knew so much.
and our job as proposal specialists.
specialists was to try and challenge them.
and extract everything we could.
out of them and also give them extra things that they...
hadn't found out themselves. So that's one of the...
started doing this research agent and it would just go...
and pull information that I took.
kind of pre, you know, I would like
and want certain stats and
The salespeople were really appreciative.
with all these reports that I was doing.
And I'm not sure.
And I think now with AI, that could
be reduced to like two minutes.
You know, so that would be...
mega useful but I think that if you
you were able to then.
productize it, it would be really a
interest in for loads of other companies as well.
Yeah, yeah, it's fun to open.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah.
[inaudible]
It's never you.
it's a big thing. It's a big thing.
Thank you for your attention.
and we request to get information.
It's right next to you.
[inaudible]
Yeah. I was like, "You're a son."
There's always a lot of things you could play.
There's a whole bunch of things.
Yeah.
I definitely see.
That's something I would appreciate just being hired by.
100%. One of the things that I'd...
you know when I was I just called it
research agent initially.
I am covered dead at the coast.
that had had so many meetings with the company that I'm
I was working for at the time and that not
mentioned that they'd had a 10 minute
£1.5 million implementation for the year.
failure of Oracle two years prior.
to meet with us so we were going to give them a mic.
Microsoft ERP, Microsoft Dynamics.
And I was just like, well, here's what.
are found in this report, went to the sales down.
and I said so really in the next presentation we want to
be talking about change management and how
how solid we are in implementation and how that filters
through with all the people and so we need blah blah blah.
and hadn't had I not done that, you know.
then can't or don't have been impressed, but it's like...
these people have done their homework, they know about.
You know, they're obviously taking care.
of how they're doing business.
And that just--
effects rather people buy from you or not in the end.
So I think it's really...
I think salespeople just don't.
think thoroughly enough unless they're at Ramstaff.
[laughter]
I think that it works.
[inaudible]
[INAUDIBLE]
and to understand the value of the current.
*unintelligible*
[inaudible]
Thank you for watching.
How can we get that churn using the cost?
[inaudible]
Yeah.
*unintelligible*
and you'll appreciate that.
[inaudible]
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly. I think it-
people just don't see it as...
like a good enough discipline to warrant the
attention but they don't realise how valuable they are.
it can be. You know, it's a huge effort.
if it's done properly.
[inaudible]
I'm gonna have to go out. I've got two more minutes.
(laughing)
[INAUDIBLE]
[inaudible]
And why I have to go is because...
you're able to. So, thank you, my pleasure.
the video.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
[inaudible]
Oh yeah. So it just...
Yeah. Yeah.
100%
Yeah.
from like how can we capitalize on them?
I'll talk to you all in the next video.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
100% I think you've got to like you know
So learn and move.
and anticipate where it's going.
you know in two years time
Do I even want to be doing beds? Probably not.
I don't know, but...
but I've been doing it for like, yeah, over 10 years now.
and it's just like habit.
But yeah, some of the other things that I've done in the past, I've done a lot of work.
Sometimes I think when there's the next low, I'll try.
just take some time out and I'll learn and
build more, do you know what I mean?
[inaudible]
[INAUDIBLE]
[laughter]
I think that does happen.
Brilliant. Oh, it's been
really lovely to meet you. I'm off the
too long as I'll have to eat tomorrow for a week.
So I'm really...
really looking forward to that going to a fall camera, Finland.
But the weather is meant to be rubbish there now.
Sunny.
And it's now it's like over task.
on the celebrity plague of loath.
as well. So, go ahead.
(laughing)
So I might have a good time, might not.
Yeah. Well, that's the question.
Thank you.
and it will definitely speak soon.
Yeah, great to meet you. Take care.
See ya. Bye-bye.